all right here's one other story I was
looking for something a little bit uh a
little bit lighter but I didn't find it
so we're stuck with this Los Angeles
officials are trying to spread the stop
the spread of the flesh-eating drug
um
zilazine I guess so x y l i z i n e
that's taken over the city the zombie
drug a Veterinary tranquilizer approved
in the U.S for cows and horses
is now flooding the illicit U.S drug
Market with dealers often cutting it
with cocaine and heroin
so these are cow tranquilizers that are
now have made their way to these city
streets
but it's most often used to cut fentanyl
the lethally potent synthetic opioid
that already kills tens of thousands of
Americans every year the drug has spread
to Los Angeles of late with new with
news crews capturing people hunched over
and on the ground strung out on the drug
the problem Los Angeles County Sheriff's
officials say is that the drug is
technically a legal substance the county
is now desperately trying to track its
presence throughout the city the DEA and
the County's Health Department have both
issued urgent warnings against the use
of the drug
quote when combined with opioids like
fentanyl as it is frequently the case it
enhances the life-threatening effects of
respiratory depression slowing or
stopping of breathing caused by opioids
increasing the risk of Overdose and
death
tracking the drug officials say will
allow them to get a sense of just how
bad the problem is and the best
practices to cut it out
nurses have described the wounds caused
by this drug as appearing as though
something is eating away at your flesh
from the inside out
that's that's where it gets the name a
zombie drug
a zombie drug because it gives people
the appearance of having their like
their flesh is rotting away like a
zombie and also because it turns them
into zombies wandering around do you
know what big Tech and big government
have in common well they both want to
silence any disagreeing voices into
submission to fight back against having
your voice censored I recommend
expressvpn the problem with big Tech is
that not only do they attempt to censor
you but they also track what you do
online what you're searching for the
videos you watch everything you click
when I use expressvpn my identity is
anonymized by a secure VPN server plus
expressvpn encrypts 100 of my internet
data for protection from hackers and
eavesdroppers expressing piano is by far
the best VPN that I've ever tried it's
VPN that's been rated number one by CNET
Business Insider and countless other
Tech Publications there's a reason for
that you'll discover if you use it
yourself what I love most about
expressvpn is that it couldn't be easier
to use the app has one button you tap it
and that's it you're protected it really
is that simple so stop letting big Tech
and big government censor and track you
defend your rights and protect yourself
expressvpn.com Walsh right now to get
three extra months free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh to get protected now
expressvpn.com Welsh everyone deserves
the best of everything including the
best night's sleep my friends at cozy
Earth are here to give you a super soft
luxurious and designer preferred betting
whether you're looking to treat yourself
or someone that you love cozy Earth has
a gift guide that can help you start
looking for the perfect gift right now
cozier's luxury bedding and loungewear
transforms lives by offering the world's
softest most luxurious and responsibly
sourced bedding their products are
temperature regulated moisture wicking
and they keep you comfortable all night
long right now because the Earth is
extending their Mother's Day sale for a
limited time while their site is
offering a discount my listeners will
still be getting up to 35 percent off
when you use promo code Walsh at
checkout I've used Cozier Tech this is
this the bedding that we have on our bed
right now can't recommend it enough
don't just take my word for it though
they have over 5 000 happy customer
reviews on their site not only do they
offer 100 night guarantee on their
sheets but their sheets get softer and
softer with every wash so what are you
waiting for invest today in a good
night's sleep when you sleep well your
life goes well cozy Earth is extending
their Mother's Day sale save up to 35
off with my promo code Walsh at
cozyearth.com that's promo code wall
should check out for up to 35 percent
off your order at cozyearth.com
um and this is
yet another reason why
um we should really be talking about
much more severe penalties for the
people who are responsible for putting
these kinds of drugs out in the market
okay the people that are actually
selling this stuff
the people that are that are responsible
for turning our cities into zombified
wastelands uh we should be discussing
much more severe penalties for them
and when I say much more severe I mean
the most severe penalties
uh the death penalty
you know I I think eventually
eventually I think many conservatives
will come around to to acknowledging
that this at least should be a
conversation
it certainly isn't something we should
recoil from uh you know just as if it's
an insane idea you know when I brought
this up a few months ago
I took a lot of heat even from
conservatives
who they didn't just disagree with
executing drug dealers they thought it
was a it's like a crazy idea it's that
we shouldn't even entertain the notion
well
I mean all you have to do is look at the
effects of these drugs this is it's it's
it is a form of murder you're giving
these drugs it's the fact that they want
it doesn't make it any different doesn't
make it better
um you are killing people in mass and
the Distributors of these drugs are mass
murderers there's no there's no question
about that and they should face uh the
penalties prescribed for people like
that they'll do it for uh this portion
of shows and move over to members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed